st. Patrick's Day coming up at
McDonald's announced the release of its
annual shamrock shake that's right
people will clap anything I love that
the shamrocks back did you hear I'm
gonna get on a horse and tell everybody
the Shamrock cheeks coming shamrock
shake coming back the shamrock shake is
so popular that McDonald's has decided
to add other Irish themed items to its
menu did you know that true story for
example for kids there's the Irish happy
meal it's gonna be fun
that's a playful treat yeah then there's
the Liam Neeson taken bacon McGriddle
pancakes then is a tribute to
oscar-nominated actress
Saoirse Ronan the Saoirse strawberry
sure cake sundae yeah
inspired by Frank McCourt's best-selling
memoir about his childhood in Ireland
there's Angela's ash Browns
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you were clapping me a minute ago and
now they're all booing yeah and ripping
up the furniture well I'll make it up to
you right now because finally McDonald's
is gonna come out with Irish curse
McNuggets and I think not true ladies
you